[Music]
because we live in this world and so
what are we going to do about it I mean
pretty clearly my kinds of things that
we've been doing up to now of course
they're very good don't necessarily
dress these issues so how are we going
to address these issues that's one of
the questions how we would include
information technology and education for
engineers and secondly because we always
do it both ways what does information
technology have to do for engine
forensic for education how can we use
information technology in order to make
education more efficient for engineers
all right so our first speaker here was
actually an expert on this field David
Wallace who is the associate professor
during will talk to us about the media
education so what I'm going to talk
about is really the new new media
possibilities that are enabled by the
use of information technology in
engineering education to provide a
little background about myself I'm the
associate director of the MIT CAD lab I
do my research in the area of computer
aided design and my teaching is in the
area of product design both at the
graduate and undergraduate levels so
what am I going to do
and first going to provide a little bit
of motivation which is at least the
angle which I am going to be coming from
in this presentation provide a few facts
things that we've learned and that are
going on talk a little bit about some
experiments that we've done in the
department at MIT and then move on to
some thoughts about teaching and
learning models in this new information
technology enabled environment
so to me this represents the space in
which we teach and we're certainly used
to in universities the notion of
presence and traditional media where
traditional media may be classrooms
lectures traditional labs tutorials and
things like that and of course now into
the fray we have the possibilities of
using new media and incorporating
telepresence as part of our educational
programs and so really ideally we'd like
to be able to work pretty seamlessly
throughout this space and some of the
key questions are how do we design our
curricula you know in an informed way so
that we can understand the difference
and when we might want to use
traditional media or new media or
presence and telepresence and it's an
important question because often the
telepresence can compete or at least
offer some of the similar sounding
educational opportunities that are lower
cost in a residential education so
moving on to motivation what I think we
need to be doing and are interested in
doing is trying to develop and test new
strategies for teaching when we have
this combined media environment that can
be applicable to a broad set of
curricula and we can understand when we
might want to use presence or
telepresence to really have the most
effective educational opportunities
possible and what I mean by that is
first of all we need high quality mass
education and we also need very high
quality residential education so we can
clearly understand and show the value of
the on-campus educational experience so
that's motivation and now I just want to
move on to some facts or some and I
would like to pose as facts and they're
still often a lot of debate about
presence or telepresence or
correspondence in a slightly more dated
form of the same thing and this is a
practi no significant difference website
and what it has is a list of over 300
reviewed journal and conference articles
that cite no significant difference
based on location ie presence or
telepresence alone it's also available
in book form so in some sense I think
the debate about presence is really open
it's it's pretty clear you can do a good
job with presence and you can do a good
job with telepresence but presence in a
sense has no inherent and baggage what
really matters is what learning and
motivational opportunities you provide
in the educational experience so it's
kind of like what do you do with the
time how well do you use this the
situation to provide an educational
experience we'll also just note that
there is also a growing significant
different site where most of the papers
are finding that remote education has an
advantage and one might speculate that
this may be because some of those
programs are fairly carefully thought
out maybe more than some of the
traditional classes so the message
really is how things are implemented is
very important no matter what you do and
it's not just the whether you're doing
it with information technology or with
people together or remotely that's
really going to be the most important
factor so you have to think carefully
about how you what your teaching
strategy is I think another observation
is that we all generally feel that we
could be doing a better job and this is
just an example from Ben Linder who is a
doctoral student in the department under
woody flowers but basically the idea is
he surveyed senior students at six major
universities asking them how much energy
was in a nine volt transistor battery
and that's a log scale on the bottom and
you see a pretty widely varying response
and and I mean it's a fair debate you
could say well should we expect them to
really be able to answer this question
or not and some people might say yes
some people might say no but on the
other hand I think we can say we would
like all of our graduating students to
be able to look at the answer they're
proposing and decide whether it's
ridiculous or not right and so so we
know you know there's all kinds of other
stories about oh you know things
happening and in some ways it's not you
know the students in some sense aren't
that much different than they were maybe
different experiences but they're you
know people just like everyone else was
historically and so we need to think
about what we can do to improve the way
we're teaching them some other facts
sticking our lecture notes online is
something that's fairly easy to do and
it certainly has administrative
advantages but in some ways it really
has a modest educational impact and this
is probably the most common applications
but it really doesn't go to the core of
trying to use the technology and new
opportunities to teach better so we
really it's not surprising because we
need to design materials to take
advantage of the media that we're using
and we need strategies and pedagogical
reasons for choosing the different media
and you know simply stated we design a
lecture in a certain way if we're gonna
stand up and talk just like I'm talking
to you now if we were going to be doing
an electronic format with multimedia
capabilities we would design it and
structure it very differently so we
shouldn't expect to be able to do just a
direct port of materials from one media
to the other and get big advantages
another area of discussion or debate is
often about what is the best way to
teach and if you look at a lot of
different materials on education and
teaching engineering is one and there's
a number of books on the subject in some
ways there really is no singular best
way to teach so of course there are
different types of people
that like to learn using different types
of formats of presentation of the
material they like to learn things in
different order theory first examples
first motivation first applications
first and there are different use
patterns some people like to hear a
story follow it along other people
really just want to go in grab the
ceiling facts so those are all different
possibilities that are really contingent
upon the people themselves in different
learning styles there's also different
types of learning whether we're trying
to do training or whether we're trying
to really teach deep theory or general
concepts and there's different types of
content and we should expect that there
may be different ways to address some of
these issues differently so it's not a
question of what is the best approach
but how do we have a framework so that
we can apply a lot of different tools
and approaches in an effective manner
and this is one hypothesis that I
certainly believe and I'll show some
experiments pertaining to in a bit that
at least the new media material
certainly can be designed so that they
can accommodate some of the different
learning style issues okay and with that
we're now going to move on to talk a
little bit about some experiments and
this is a new media teaching model that
is a result of some experiment so I'll
just give it to you up front but the
gist of it is to have students cuddy
study codify material using lectures and
quotes in a sense that are online and
then following that up with experiential
activity or mentoring with someone that
has experience or wisdom if you will
it's hard to codify and then providing
the opportunity for in practice
application to really consolidate
learning in a deep way in that
particular model I was based on some
experiments where we first tried to sit
down and design a framework that we
could provide the codified materials
online and in a sense in lieu of a
lecture and really motivating that
structure around
different learning styles idea and then
once we wanted to do that really
evaluate it how well does it compare to
a regular classroom and if we can use
these materials in lieu of a class how
can we spend time differently with
students versus a traditional lecture so
I'm just going to move on so we
developed a general template for
providing lectures and this is for
actually an implementation of it but for
a traditional 90-minute lecture and I
just want to note down the right side is
what would be the equivalent of the
lecture divided up into ninety-four
different subtopics and if you follow it
through it's more or less going to read
like a story if you go point to point it
provides you very parallel access into
just about every part of the lecture
right now we're in a section on actually
related to prototyping and actually
powder Prime things and in that the
content is divided up and it's hard for
you to read but essentially this is the
there's a bin which is for why do I want
to know this if there's any theory
behind it that's where the theories
provided procedural information which is
how you do the applique it's really an
application an example so the students
can very quickly or conveniently if you
will tab between different types of
learning information and then finally
within the subject the students so we're
looking at how to so that's the
procedural part of priming they can play
a video which is annotated so they can
watch and listen they can listen to
audio and look at the pictures or they
can go through a very traditional read
and look at the pictures just like an
online not textbook and we've
implemented four lectures in this way to
for product design and to related to
classical control
once we had in particular the
prototyping lecture implemented we
wanted to compare this to our regular
classroom teaching so we had half of the
class take the web lecture and the other
half have a traditional lecture on the
same content and they all had access to
the same textbook but you either had a
class or you didn't and then they had a
project and an outside group evaluate
the project and what we could do is then
track a lot of information track how
they did on the projects according to
the jury and also do focus groups to try
to learn a little bit about what we're
doing so just to compare first of all
the juries scoring of the prototyping
project and what this is on the left is
if we divide the class group and the web
group but we look at all of the
assignments they did over the term where
they were taught in the class and the
same thing and what we can show is that
they do are indeed expected to perform
the same and when we look at how they
did on the assignment in fact it was
about a 7.3 percent difference so in
other words the people who only had the
web-based experience did a little bit
better than the people who had to class
and statistically for these data it's
about a one in 100 chance of seeing that
difference in the mean where they
actually really were performing the same
so there's a reasonably statistical
evidence that to say that they perform
differently let's think a little bit
about why here are some of the things we
can design the online material to do
it's a classroom lecture 90 minutes most
lectures are either 1 hour 90 minute or
90 minutes both are longer than people's
attention spans and if we look at how
many as usual whacks at it the students
took online took to start to cover the
entire lecture the average was about 3
which corresponds to 33 minutes per
session which is
very close if you look at some of the
data to what people's attention spans
are this little snapshot down at the
bottom is essentially the number of
people studying as a function of time of
day and the only slot that's quiet is
between 4 a.m. and 8 a.m. spike is
actually at lunchtime and we also found
through the focus groups that it was
they like being able to do the studying
by themselves because they didn't feel
peer pressure they felt they could spend
a lot time where they didn't understand
things and not feel like they were not
as smart as the next person in the class
basically we also have data where we can
and we had these parallel delivery paths
and we can show that there were groups
that were movie centric there were
groups that were taxed an image centric
and there were groups that will switch
back and forth probably based on the
content of the section and whether they
thought a different medium might have
different types of information so what
we can say is that looking at these
differences one of the other nice
features when we try experiments with
new media materials is that we can
actually track and understand a lot of
things and learn about how to do better
but given the notion that this lecture
like that online can work the question
then becomes how do we use the class
time and so to follow up what we did is
of course we next year the entire class
uses the web material and we asked them
to prepare beforehand by studying this
but the class is divided up in to two
groups and taught differently in person
one group I call it the active classroom
so it's a lecture where we're following
active learning type of guidelines but
the gist of it is we give a complete
second coverage of the material which is
potentially a positive thing for the
other group we actually make no attempt
to cover all of the material but we just
go and work with them and do some things
with them the cover part of the material
then we follow the same prototypes where
they all do the same sort of project and
an external review of how they do
and in this case game we shouldn't show
we would expect them to perform the same
based on their other assignments and we
see a difference of about over 10% and
in this case the from a statistical
standpoint there's a chance of about 1
in 1,000 of seeing that big of a
difference in mean when the two groups
were actually the same so it seems that
that combination works pretty well and a
game we might think well why and earlier
on I said a lot of education is about
motivation and preparation and studying
which is important on the left is in a
survey how the students rated their
preparation of beforehand and so in blue
are the people that essentially thought
they were coming to a lecture and the
red is the people who thought that they
were going to do some things and of
course you can see that the people in
red were much more motivated to prepare
ahead these are the actual data because
they were all studying the web lecture
and what we can see is that the 60th
percentile person coming to a classroom
was less prepared than the least
prepared person that was going to come
and do an exercise so there was some
strong motivational differences and in
fact the only difference is in the
instructions between the two groups is
one set you're strongly encouraged to
review the complete lecture before class
and the other one will assume that
you've covered it and will be working on
things in our class period so you can
use the mix of information technology
and traditional approaches to provide
strong motivational forces and when we
ask students about and this is in a
survey if I could have only had one of
the forms of instruction if we look at
the people who had the class and the web
60% said they while I take the web only
if we look at the people that had the
experience essentially 80 percent said
they would take the experi
it's only and that was in the fact that
they really wouldn't we didn't cover all
of the information there so if they took
the experience only they would have
missed a huge part of what they really
needed to learn but they placed a very
high value on that experience and so in
some sense one of the messages is when
we're working with the students we
should be trying to do things with them
and things that are not readily codified
in other forms so where might this type
of model apply and so this model was
which we were trying to support was
studying codified materials using
appropriate Aiki based approaches
experiential activities and then in
practice application and what I want to
add is each lecture took about 500 hours
and $100 500 hours to produce for about
an hour of lecture so there's some
overhead and preparing them but
certainly this seems like an appropriate
form where this knowledge base is stable
there's a lot of students or a lot of
customers if you want to think of it
that way and they may or may not be
super interested in learning the
material because we can bring in very
high production value we also actually
have used this model at the Ford Design
Institute for their technical employee
training and what it's probably not
appropriate for is emerging knowledge
where there's a small customer base and
very strong interest and motivation to
learn on their own and you don't need
essentially some of the production value
so now with that through what I just
want to talk and close up with are some
thoughts about teaching in this new
media environment and this is based on
work done by a committee with several
different disciplines involved in the
department of mechanical engineering how
my time wise
okay should be just about right so when
we worked on this and what we really
wanted to do is try to find a way to
think about all the possibilities and
how we might apply them in some
different teaching strategies and these
are some methods that have really been
around a long time one which we call the
Socratic method which is independent
study guided by mentoring which is more
or less what I've described just in time
which is the notion that you're working
on an application and you learn when you
need to because you've encountered a
problem and finally a classical
scientific discovery mode of learning
through observation study and hypothesis
and experiments and so really what we
think needs to be done is to identify
the combinations of material delivery
hard facilities and interactions for
these different types of learning models
and trying to understand what one suit
different types of materials and
teaching goals what we envision for well
all of these is one thing is that most
students will have laptops and for the
socratic we think that we'll have these
types of codified lecture modules that
support different learning styles and
then we can combine them with mentoring
experiences and these mentoring me
experiences may be mini lectures they
may be some form of a classical lecture
it could be personal mentoring that
could be electronic forums it could be
online quizzes with feedback it could be
a studio environment and there's
activities in all those areas and we'd
like to think about how we would use
them and one thing I can say that I feel
pretty confident about maybe a bit
controversial but at least for me I find
that 15 minutes of direct contact with
you know two or three students is easily
worth a couple hours of me standing and
lecturing so that's kind of what's
driving that model
for the just-in-time model of Education
what we think is neat is essentially a
marketplace of learning modules so that
students or employees are working on
projects and when they encounter
problems they can find the resources to
learn the bits that they need at the
time and the reason we think there's
going to be some sort of a module
marketplace is that the projects are
often very different and diverse and so
it's hard to predict upfront what types
of codified material would have and it
would be I think too great a task for
any one Institute to produce all of the
materials that are needed in an
appropriate way and you essentially need
highly customizable curricula and this
is one of the challenges in two double-a
nine which is a project design course
that we teach where different teams of
students are all working on different
projects and so they run into different
problems as they're working throughout
the term and finally the scientific
discovery model we and we envision this
is a picture of you know be sort my the
high school chemistry lab concept where
but really the classroom and the
laboratory are integrated and there's a
lot of interesting issues related to the
use of physical space versus virtual
labs of haptic devices for example to
virtual simulations or physical tool
boxes that need to support this type of
environment so there's a lot of
potential combinations of traditional
and information technology approaches
that need to be thought about so in
summary I think there's quite a bit to
be optimistic about as there's a lot of
new teaching opportunities that are
arising and I think what we need to be
doing is thinking about how we can use
them effectively the one thing I will
say though is that things are moving
very fast there are a number of open
universities virtual universities
companies or organizations offering
courses that very low cost and so I
think now is really the time that we
need to explore and develop
strategy for teaching in this
environment so that's the end of my talk
[Applause]
[Music]
well I mean that I mean I can that
particular metric you know that's one
that's not as derived as most of the
data that I put up there whereas careful
and that's to be honest my gut feeling
and I guess to I guess
provide some substance to that in the
graduate course that I'm teaching I now
lecture a number of the lectures are
using this approach and then we work on
activities I do some traditional
lectures but just about every third week
I don't lecture and I have 10 minutes or
15 minute meetings with two students at
a time see what they're doing and I work
with them and I feel that the results
are better so that's a much more
qualitative statement but that's kind of
what I base that on and I find that 15
minutes to be practical if I you know
you could spend more time and it would
be great but that's the chunk of time
that it becomes a manageable proposition
for me as an individual doing this so
an area that was growing then back to
where do you see things going
[Music]
residential education sure I mean I
guess for some thoughts on that its core
speculation just like have any of anyone
else's I guess asking the question my
own opinion is that the inn first of all
I think the line between distance
learning and residential learning will
become more blurred and that I think
even in a residential university some
things will be done almost in a distance
learning style such as the very codified
materials examples of that I can't they
could look the references up but I know
of lots of cases where they begun to
offer courses on campus both
internet-based and traditional and the
internet-based kind of clearly went out
in terms of what the students want to do
so the lines will become blurred but I
think that what the residential
universities really need to do is focus
on the unique part that you can't really
do at a distance so that there's still a
very you know strong motivation for
wanting to have a residential education
because you can work essentially with
your peers and also with people that
have wisdom to impart that can't be
readily codified and is easily
disseminated now in the distance
learning mode you can still try to do
things to help impart that so for
example you might set up a scenario
where in in the maybe you're
broadcasting a type of learning
experience where you have some students
who are kind of up and actually working
and interacting almost in a mentoring
way with the faculty and then there's
observers at remote sites and that can
help bring some of the flavor of the
one-on-one experience but it's still
from a motivational standpoint very
different then
you know the knowledge of the students
that they're gonna have to go and talk
and do these things and be you know seen
by others so so I don't think there'll
be a complete replacement but there may
be a shift in scale and and what's done
in different ways it seems easy to
embrace these kinds of technologies when
you try to present theory or topical
knowledge like the knowledge part what
about the know how like how to solve
problems I think again I would point you
make I think is a good one and it goes
back to I think that things that can be
readily readily codified are very
appropriate for this type of approach
things that can't be is where the the
value-added and the experience is and
that you know in sense but know how
that's procedural which is in fact lots
of times what you see in employee
training programs at companies that's
just as gotta file as anything else the
kind of wisdom of actually doing an
experience with experiments a with
someone who has a lot of depth in that
field is something that you're going to
have much more difficult time packaging
if you will in this way and that's where
I think that you know a big part of the
residential education value should be
we may have taken bill difficulties so
David's going to be on the education
panel coming right up so please grill
them someone
[Applause]
[Laughter]
all right mention about the standard
maybe if this by the way is doing better
he's professor of mechanical engineering
he's a deputy director for the single
for lives he's gonna talk to us today
about the MIT Singapore Alliance for
education
so I will start with what was going to
be an audio video and that was going to
be a video with your own personal voice
over
all right so SMA is the Singapore MIT
alliance and this is a little video that
we made for promotional purposes but it
also gives you a sense of the program
this was launched to last year the first
class would be graduating this summer
and there are two programs initially in
advanced materials and in high
performance conversation and the as you
can see is a very significant distance
complement that I'll be describing a
little more in a moment the program
begins by the students in Singapore with
about a month of various teaching
activities they then come here at MIT
this here is indicating what they do
while in Singapore the originally says
as MIT the beginning of the program the
two days is focused on sort of the
spirit of techno corner ship within MIT
with
as well as a continuation of the more
formal activities that they do you turn
your mic on please how much particularly
enjoyed my lectures during their time as
the when they returned from MIT back to
to Singapore they continued on with
about a month of classes at Singapore
and then begins the distance aspect of
it and the key component of the distance
aspect is that you saw MIT students in
the classroom there and now in a moment
you will be seeing the Singaporean
students sitting in Singapore we send
two streams to Singapore one is the
video stream which is all the usual
talking head business the other stream
is the data stream all right which is
essentially uncompressed PowerPoint
slides and other data aspects that
therefore arrive uncorrupted on the
Singapore side the facilities that
you're seeing here are the ones at MIT
there is a mirror sight at Singapore and
in fact in some of the courses we even
beamed internally to MIT you're seeing
that now from the Singaporean the SMA
students perspective where you saw the
two large screens at the front of the
room the left is the video stream the
right is the data stream and in fact
these are the kinds of PowerPoint
animations that are used in some of the
lectures and I'll be talking about that
a bit subsequently as well this again is
from the Singaporean side Jacob white on
the left they see him now in the inset
here and on the right was the data
stream that he sends over which you see
here as well and again that's from the
the SMA student perspective what was
being used on the left is a document
camera which is simply a higher and
higher data integrity version of a
blackboard there's a significant
asynchronous component in which all of
the various lecture materials digitized
videos lecture notes slides are posted
on websites and integrated using
effectively a system related to the
command system used at MIT here you see
the Singaporean students viewing
professor Barrett CMAs the sequel
alright having seen him one slide they
now see him through the digitized videos
which we found to be a very effective
way for them to be able to review
material there's also other various by
this point the standard mechanisms for
them to search through the material and
to pick the various pieces that they're
that they're looking for in addition to
the distance interactions many of the
students spend time at MIT in particular
all the PhD students and here you see
them commingled with MIT students on
campus and also talking about research
projects here with Professor suresh
research is a significant component of
the SMA program and I'll talk about that
a bit more later
here it's appropriate to indicate that
the third program is housed primarily
but not exclusively in mechanical
engineering you see professor Chun and
professor Hart and their counterparts in
Singapore designing the manufacturing
program which is the third of the three
academic programs there are also major
players from the Sloan School in that
program as there are in fact in several
of the programs that are currently
launched and so I think that is about it
this is just they're just saying how
great everything is and that and I think
at this point I can
I can conclude seems to have concluded
for me
and so what I'd like to do now is make a
few there are a few uplifting moments at
the end that I spared you yeah but I'd
like to do now is use that as data and
make a few observations most of which I
think are quite obvious first it's an
experiment in teaching and research and
I think you saw that I put at a distance
but that's only really part of what all
of this is about and I'd like to first
make some general remarks the key one is
that SMA is not really typical of
distance efforts though the first is
there's a focus on an elite graduate
cohort the students that are admitted
essentially past the same kind of
mustard that we require of all our own
students here at MIT in terms of GREs
and of course letters of recommendation
so again the focus is on elite as
opposed to many other distance efforts
which are which are more for the
unwashed masses both teaching and
research components figure prominently
again many distance efforts are focused
on information transfer much more the
formal teaching as opposed to the more
labor intensive research side there are
both distance and face-to-face elements
as I indicated the students come here
and the faculty go there all right so
there's a significant component of what
we consider more classical modalities
that are not facilitated by technology
in any significant way there's a very
high faculty to student ratio many
distance education efforts are are
stimulated by the desire to be able to
much more inexpensively educate a much
larger group of students in this case we
seem to have almost maximized the the
inverse of that ratio in terms of the
resources that are being devoted to the
students there's a strong emphasis on
interaction all right this is not a case
where there's a lot of tools that are
developed put online and they become a
one-on-one activity between the student
and the tool there's a lot of
interaction between the faculty and the
students there are strong links with MIT
residential initiatives many of the
programs so for example stimulated
immense degrees here on campus based on
material developed within the Singapore
MIT allowance alliance
there's also a very strong partnership
emphasis with Singapore there are
Singaporean faculty involved so that
students even when they're in a distance
mode relative to MIT faculty have
Singaporean faculty from NUS and NTU
that serve as as local face-to-face
faculty in the usual sense so there's
there's always this component of a more
traditional environment the there are
very advanced facilities and technical
support this is not the kind of thing
one can do in one's own garage it yet
and finally there is a quasi and typical
Geographic framework that was apparently
maximized for frequent flyer miles
rather than convenience the yrfi our
dear Provost Bob Brown when he set up
this program and finally there's because
of all that a rather non-trivial price
tag again distance education sometimes
is seen as the the economic panacea for
for educating a larger and larger group
of people certainly they should not
emulate the Singapore MIT alliance if
that is their objective so let me then
make a few more specific observations
first related to teaching and then just
a few on research the first on teaching
is that technology is no replacement for
and can significantly detract from
scholarly organized complete and
effective development by which I mean
preparation and assimilation of
educational material and to give you one
example of that this is very anecdotal
obviously we had one course in which
there was a great emphasis on more
dynamic presentations and there was not
too much background material available
we had another course which had much
more detailed lecture notes but much
more static and less stimulating in some
sense lectures and we found that the
students although they certainly enjoyed
the dynamic presentations would much
prefer that we spent our time and making
sure there was always adequate codified
material for them to be able to
appropriate and subsequently apply the
material this is a bit peculiar perhaps
to the SMA program in the sense that
we're developing new graduate curricula
so existing textbooks are not readily
available and in as much background
was more imperative developed for each
course but nevertheless I think there's
a more general message to be taken away
I'd like to I guess that it's not the
right button I'd like to go back to the
asterisk which says it can significantly
detract from but need not we saw a
number of examples that Dave Wallace
showed we're obviously content
technology was enhancing it I've chosen
to take this more negative view because
I think there's a lot more material out
there that's not exciting and the kinds
of things that Dave is doing is
exception not the rule
this really refers to as I just
described content technology and somehow
in some sense using technology to
enhance the way that the content is
presented right there's another aspect
of technology which is obviously crucial
to the SMA effort which is transmission
technology you saw there some of the
live beaming sessions that are done we
have the classroom here at MIT and does
the MIT faculty member there's the MIT
students present that is live simulcast
over Internet - all right to the
singapura site all right obviously
having all those pieces work is
absolutely critical to the success of
the program and I think the summary at
this point is that advanced video
conferencing technology is reasonably
effective and reasonably reliable or
reasonably reliable and reasonably
effective issues remain audio and video
clarity you saw the audio and video
clarity we've actually had at least as
much trouble with the audio as the video
which is a bit surprising bandwidth and
compression are an issue we have MIT
faculty that are extremely animated in
Singapore that comes out as kind of a
throwback to claymation all right after
they've been sent through this low-pass
filter apart from sedating our faculty
that doesn't appear to be a near-term
their problem and it's something that
has to be addressed a queueing inflow is
also critical we all take advantage or
take grant take for granted in an
environment like this how easily it is
to pick up on peripheral cues in order
to know where the attention has to be
focused at a distance a lot of that
cueing goes away partially because of
clarity partially because of camera
angles partially because of one's
ability to see the remote site on a
screen which tends to be rather small
and at the back of the classroom so for
all those reasons things are not quite
where they should be but they're not bad
and the feedback is generally good based
on over a hundred live beamed sessions
and also on student performance yes it's
just not working
[Music]
keep the other one also yeah then you
get electrocuted but in terms of student
performance we did comparisons not quite
as scientific as as Dave's in terms of
the MIT cohort and the SMA cohort and we
found that they were statistically
indistinguishable in fact so much so
that the data looked rigged but I think
that the the takeaway is not so much the
data as it is the fact that the
Singaporean students are the students in
Singapore we're able to learn the
material at a rate similar and an
ability similar to that of the MIT
students here on campus observation
three is that lectures without student
participation or a real waste of
expensive SMA resources and as opposed
to alternatives such as lectures with
much interaction or recitations and
tutorials and the reason is if we pay
facility charges we have in a very
expensive room technician charges we
have two or three technicians typically
on each side making sure that the event
transpires smoothly internet2 and ISDN
access charges all these live simulcasts
are done over i2 or ISDN off our extra
compensation because of the fact that
Singapore is 13 hours different from us
the lectures go take off typically
between 7:00 and 9:00 in the morning and
8:00 and 10:00 in the evening if you add
all that up and this is all being done
for real-time sessions and all you have
is a
remember that spends 99% of the time
talking that's not really a very good
use of those resources and in some sense
this has only made more clear what's
already clear at MIT which and that's
why I put the SMA in parentheses at MIT
there are lots of charges and costs
associated with giving a lecture as well
they're not as easily attributed to
things like technicians and all the rest
but they're clearly there and once again
you might act you might ask is that
really a very good use of resources and
that's precisely I think one of the
points that Dave Wallace is making but
of course what enables all this is web
archiving an integration so that you can
get the material before class and then
use the class for more interesting
interactive maneuvers and in fact that
has been used very successfully so far
at SMA we archive the digitized lecture
videos the slides and the lecture notes
and this provides for a very rich
environment and on when I go to
Singapore I often will circulate through
the cubicles where the students sit and
in fact you see them very often going
back to these videos of the lectures to
see what were the key points and they
also have access to the lecture notes
which develop things in more detail and
they seem to that way in some sense a
Tech's were a replacement for the more
constant and redundant interactions that
would occur if they were not at a
distance on research I have just two
very obvious observations the first one
is that most MIT faculty already engaged
in some form of distance research all
right back to MIT while on travel or to
institutions as students of colleagues
the data for that is that it's certainly
difficult to find an MIT faculty member
at MIT they must be somewhere and
wherever they are they must be
interacting with their students back at
home in order to continue making
progress on the research front on the a
slightly less obvious observation is
that distance research can be enhanced
by really now standard technology a
one-to-one video conferencing which is
just a euphemism for net meeting and
variants thereof slightly more
sophisticated shared collaborative
applications it's now very easy to take
scribbled notes as you would present to
a student sitting across from you put it
through a scanner have that integrated
into a shared and collaborative
whiteboard so that you can annotate
and the student at the other side in
this case in Singapore can annotate it
simultaneously and again that time of a
session is almost as good as what you
might be able to construct with a
student sitting on the other side of the
desk
and finally there are various hardware
devices tablets and other input systems
that make this shared collaborative
application usage a little easier and in
fact we've we've integrated all this
together into little individual distance
kits that we give to the faculty
participating in the SMA program so that
they have all the access to the both the
software and the hardware that they need
in terms of interacting with their
students and finally then by way of
conclusions even at 12,000 miles
teaching and research remain well they
remain teaching and research and that's
more or less by construction where a lot
of this program is in some sense not
revolutionary its reactionary trying to
replicate some of the very good things
about MIT at a distance obviously some
of the things are a little more
revolutionary but we're trying to keep
it balanced between the two good
transmission technology is absolutely
essential and I would say it's not quite
there but it's almost there as you can
as you could tell from my earlier
comments I'm a little not quite as
enthusiastic about content technology
unless it's very carefully applied
finally some regular face-to-face
interactions are still crucial in
particular for research I think in terms
of establishing a rapport with the
research student which most of us have
now had done in terms of launching the
research aspect of SMA that would be
clearly impossible if there were only
net interactions that were available
that's all I have prepared and I'd be
glad to take any any questions that you
might have
[Applause]
setting up a research program with for
example with the bureau collagen love it
were started leading the project
basically by events and in the beginning
these people that were involved only
knew each other vicariously in the sense
that they only knew the two project
directors in the tutor to Anu knew each
other and it was very interesting to me
that over the period of three or four
months when those intensive projects
heard there was a real camaraderie and
sharing that went on between two people
working on the project even though they
never saw each other the first people
with video conference I'm just wondering
if there was any
personal infrastructure building that
occurred here between the students
probably to a certain extent I would I
think that the students come in and and
they're immediately blasted with sort of
a standard MIT kind of graduate program
and so there is not that much there's
not much time left actually for sort of
the more cohort building activities
we've actually lightened up some of the
programs precisely because we felt that
that didn't given the distance there was
not enough time left on the side for
those kinds of relationships so I think
the answer is that that it's probably a
little different in terms of research
group to research group and faculty to
students in terms of priorities as to
what they have on their plate what they
have to get done first but I certainly
agree with you that in the cases where
it did happen it was clear that there
was a way to develop some kind of a some
kind of a report electronically in
remote coordination of research due to
the fact that there has to be some
attention given to documenting results
in order to facilitate the communication
is that is that something you've seen as
a benefit that well it's something I've
certainly seen before in terms of when
again when faculty travels sometimes
they have a better sense of exactly
what's going on and when they're when
they're here and and and to a certain
extent that's also happened in the in
the SMA program in the sense that that
there's a more conscious effort all
right to make sure that both sides know
what's going on and therefore
communications tend to be a little
better the one thing you actually a
comment reminds me of is that there's
also this usual wisdom about progress
being better because if you're separated
by 12 hours of course there's one side
that's working right they pass the ball
to the other side of it the fallacy in
that argument of course is that graduate
students already are pre cest by 12
hours all right
and so in fact everybody's up at the
same time so that has not panned out
quite the way we anticipated
what's the finish that point to all the
expenses
[Music]
yeah few million yeah well there's
several there's several answers to that
the the the several aspects the answer
that the first is that the at the same
ways MIT ceases and as an investment in
an experiment in terms of understanding
how these kinds of technologies can be
applied right so so does Singapore all
right and obviously Singapore would like
to position itself and is and is in fact
positioning itself as a hub for
education in Southeast Asia all right
and in as much knowing how these
technologies can be applied is is
obviously going to be crucial so there's
there's a there's a clear sense from
both the MIT and from the Singapore side
that understanding how to use these
technologies is is very important the
other thing of course is it's not only
twenty five students that would you saw
were various snapshots
all right the steady-state population of
students will be more like fifty times
five or 250 students and as you know an
MIT education in fact is not so cheap
either so if you do the if you do the
multiplication alright it's it's not
such a not such compare but but the key
point is that this is really seen as a
way of exploring what can be done
alright within the sort of context and
confines of what we consider to be
quality top-level
education using some of these new
modalities in a creative way so if that
yes sorry
or for one course right well no yeah no
I won't know but but but the reason I
won't is that in fact I've mentioned
beginning there's both research and and
teaching components so in fact by giving
you by dividing the total number by the
number of courses right I'm applying a
research overhead on each of those
courses which is not very easy by the
end of five years including cost both on
the MIT side and the Singapore side it
will be well over a hundred million
dollars
the group in Singapore is a definitely a
trip to any school there yes of course
I'm sorry what school is that what you
would have seen on the or which would
have heard on the audio is that there
there to actor there's more than two now
there are two primary universities in
Singapore National University of
Singapore Nanyang Technological
University both are involved note the
program was just launched last year so
as of now the answer is simple exactly
zero hopefully over the next five years
yeah as I said there'll be roughly 35
times five about 150 students graduating
each year from the professional master's
degree and in addition over the course
of the program I guess there will be
about maybe 50 or 60 mm engined PhD
research candidates that are also
[Applause]
MIT and Dave Wallace also from MIT and
so what's the format is each panelist
will say a few words depending on what
they feel like saying then we'll have
discussion of that and then we'll have a
group discussion of everything all
together
[Music]
okay you know since we have distinct
colleagues we'll be speaking on their
programs I'll be very brief some of the
things that you've heard in terms of how
we are trying to conduct education and
one that has to be considered in the
context of a lot of other things we are
doing in the deposit mechanical
engineering so let me just say a few
words and then I'll ask our colleagues
here to speak on what they have in mind
at MIT in our department we create a
complete new undergraduate curriculum
and we teach in a very different fashion
we graduate our first class last year
under this new curriculum so this
curriculum is simply put an integrated
way of teaching to provide better
context for learning so for example in
the area of fluids thermodynamics and
heat transfer we have one sequence so we
do not have a separate subjects for heat
for thermodynamics as such but we teach
all three combined so that we can
provide better context for learning we
have four of these sequences and we are
writing new books and new books will be
published by Oxford University Press
under the special series known as MIT
Pappalardo series of mechanical
engineering books so thanks to Neil
Pappalardo and Jane pepper others
support we are able to create and Amin
fund for book writing and hopefully from
now into perpetuity we'll have lots of
books coming out in the first series of
undergraduate core textbooks will be
coming out sometime I hope next year or
so so we have invested greater money
supporting faculty effort to write new
textbook developing new teaching
materials and new ways of teaching and
so forth in addition we will be spending
we just got support from this MIT
Microsoft Alliance I guess whereby we
will be developing new ways of teaching
they've always talked about three
different modes of learning and you know
to do that we'll be actually developing
all the details as to how those things
can be implemented so one of the things
we are
we are restructuring or we are modifying
our lecture halls so we can indeed teach
these two different modes of learning
name its scientific weight scientific
discovery and Socrates web mode of
learning will be tried in a new lecture
hall so we are building new lecture hall
and so that's that's on ongoing as well
so we'll be tearing apart our existing
lecture hall starting January and so and
then on top of that to implement this
hands-on kind of teaching we have
renovated all about teaching labs and
some of you may see it tomorrow and so
it has taken greater investment in terms
of both the time of the faculty and
financial resource to make it happen and
so we are continuing to put greater of
investment in these areas and the some
of my colleagues say today we're
investing too much money in
undergraduate education but then when
you actually look at what we have done
most of our investment in education has
gone into graduate education now I won't
belabor the point I will give you the
details but most of our faculty members
teach three hours a week and the rest of
the time do research and supervise and
graduate students so in proportion to
the investment made in terms of faculty
salary what have you clearly graduate
education has been getting most of our
attention in recent years we try to make
sure that our undergraduates get the
best education any institution anywhere
can provide and that's the thing we have
been doing and we haven't helped great
dear by our alumni with a vision as to
what it is that MIT ought to do to make
MIT the price where students should come
and learn so we have these many
concurrent activities taking place and I
think in in that context you have to
understand some of these things taking
place so it's part of now the MIT
Cambridge program there will be
something very similar to MIT Singapore
program which is which will be launched
sometime very soon the money will come
out of a British government and the UK
government and unit and will be again
launching some are similar but parts
very different in content and so forth
with
the University of Cambridge in England
again with the hope of changing
cambridge to be more like MIT you know
that's sort of what i we are told and
that this department will be the first
department to be engaged in that
experiment so we will be accepting six
students from Singapore and we'll be
sending six of our students to Cambridge
and one of them do we have to work out
is to make sure that when our students
go over to Cambridge indeed they can get
all the credit hours that they need to
satisfy so they can graduate in the same
time period so as many of these things
are going on and in indeed there are
lots of exciting things happening here
at MIT and I just don't have enough time
to go into all of this but perhaps
during the next turn this evening and
tomorrow if you have any questions we'll
be very happy to answer anything you
have in mind we did I'd like to
introduce our colleagues then Herman
from Purdue and he'll be talking to us
about what's going on at with you then
thank you could you go ahead and try to
turn on the projector please well it's
my pleasure to be here with you today
I've really enjoyed the workshop and I
thought what I'd do is just briefly and
just take a couple minutes I think we're
all going to just take five or so
minutes and then open it up to the to
the group but I just touched on a few
points of things going on at Purdue some
of which might be unique some of which
you might see going elsewhere and the
four topics in IT and education that I
highlighted our virtual labs distance
design teams innovation realization lab
and then web-based courseware and those
are some topics that I believe other
folks are working on as well the when I
start with web-based course where we
have done some experiments with courses
call it web enhanced or web-based and
most recent example is a graduate course
of combustion course and there's the
components that come to mind and that we
have the lectures on streaming video so
there are basically the students can
anytime through the semester a tap into
the lectures very similar to the last
presentation we have then in addition to
that PowerPoint notes in parallel I
think that the strategy that's been used
in that is the notes are not complete
the notes have some blanks to sort of
encourage this active haptic
participation I guess you'd say in in
note-taking and try to engage the
students a bit more
so those are the five or the six areas
like and here's the topics I was just
talking about we have the on-demand
viewing of lectures and sort of an
uncertified stat is this is Professor
Bohr and combustion this semester the
latest one ten hits per student per
lecture we think that's the students in
the class and I can reluck at the
lectures downloadable notes with blanks
one of the interesting things which
number of you may have as well as sort
of the frequently asked questions
bulletin board where as students begin
to ask questions and they began to be
consistencies begin to developed and the
faculty member works diligently to
create a very nice answer to that and
post it there's a chat room involved and
then as divided the class up into
distance study groups and assigned
students to be leaders in those study
groups I think those are about five
students or so now the great sheets
online
the next
I think I'm talking about is just
briefly distance design teams we've
heard some some of that this involves in
an interdisciplinary
multi-university design teams and
there's a number of experiments going on
at Allen binnington's here from leaves
there's some experiments with Purdue and
am the one that Alan's involved with is
Arizona State leads Boeing and
rolls-royce if I recall so this is
undergraduate design team working across
those boundaries industry advisors as
well and then internet and white
abilities enable that by the next slide
as well there's a project that it's
called the innovation realization lab it
impacts on something we heard it at
lunch this is an NSF project between
Kranz which is a management of the
business school Purdue and engineering
schools this is where we pair an MBA
student with a PhD student in the last
two years of his report or PhD and the
goal is then to get the sorry there's a
typo there that's PhD the goal is to
commercialize the PhD the technology
coming out of the thesis of the two
students work together and there's some
network distance collaboration involved
with that so that gets to this last some
of the comments at lunch and the very
last thing I'll briefly talk about is
some virtual lab experiments some of our
faculty use animation and classes I'm
sure that's common with you and then one
thing that reaches down to the high
school of high school level is something
called remote scope and if I could have
the next slide just briefly this is
where we've at Purdue we're trying to
work with the high school in terms of
Education inquiry-based science and so
there's a set of microscopes man by
experts at at the University and then in
principle the high school students are
able to remotely access a set of slides
the next there's multiple samples you
can see multiple magnifications and the
stood
can control those few parameters very
last slide gives you some overview of of
that and in principle it's a it's a
network of multiple types of microscope
scanning probes optical near focal
scanning in principle SEMS as well and
then a set of of high schools thank you
we hear from more speakers first and
then he pushes and
[Music]
of course modules which can be used at
the senior level
[Music]
my presentation of a confederation just
want to schedule the goals and
expectations and some of the case
studies we developed and the summation
the goals and objectives are to show the
relevance office
SAPT education SMED stands for science
education and information technologies
examples develop the methodology to
achieve these goals and objectives
shaping the future of engineering
education we have heard many people talk
here national organization simply say
the same thing in the states you
couldn't say the same thing they want to
integrate theory design and practice so
what we did here was to develop the case
cover and this case study identify a
problem there bring the real problem
into the classroom but is you bi can see
both education and take the cotton
conversation document it take pictures
videos and put a button missing you all
together and the students will have
access to so we have web-based material
about video about cd-rom and we can get
started
the second uh particular for us was to
show the education of students to
sophomore year not because not because
they have a city or the city sports but
what we found out was a profit from
engineering because they will see the
rubbers of science and math top due
process what engineers do so most of
them transfer to the system so what we
taught us to show them to reverse of
science math principles by using both we
get stories
some examples of the case studies this
is a della steam plant case sorry I
think I should briefly describe this to
you what happened here is after regular
maintenance of a turbine generator set
they started the turbine generator and
the system started vibrating and the
vibration was so heavy that the building
started shaking and people ran Alto
skelter so we could we could be
documented it and got the problem to the
classroom right intervene right from the
plant manager to the technician to show
how decision-making is done in the real
world and what vibrations are and why
vibration their course in vibrations is
necessary and how the vibration
principles are related to physics math
etc so mechanical engineering vibration
safety and instrumentation was the
topics we looked at and we developed
another case study with NASA design of
the solid rocket booster Philly joint to
consider ethical safety reliability risk
schedule and cost factors ethical
considerations in engineering design
statistical methods and this is joint
effort with NASA Marshall and then
learning from failure we have another
case study that is the Challenger
episode to teach the students what
happens if you make a wrong decision and
how wrong decisions can be made in
engineering designs and we are working
with we worked with oakna tu si is a
Japanese company they do real-time
online auto auctions short to show
students the difference between
satellite and web-based systems
and this is an interesting case study we
worked with chick-fil-a and I was
surprised to know that the operating
system you select for the point-of-sale
terminal where you have the employee
selling you the sandwich makes a
difference in time in the delivery time
of your sandwich say for example if they
give you if they select window C or C
system operating system versus auntie
system you can get the sandwich at five
minutes earlier final respects our
difference I thought this is an
excellent case to show to the students
why they need to know about these
operating systems and we had the support
from the CEO of chick-fil-a and we
brought this into the classroom another
case study we did was with nuclear power
plant and to show thermodynamics heat
transfer and nuclear power and this is
the design of a cooling tower again
this is also an interesting case study
this is planning a maintenance out page
we were given access into the power
plant when they were doing a maintenance
outage it's a two million dollar project
we were there with our cameras and tape
recorders taped the whole thing and
developed the case study the idea here
is to show how a huge project is handled
in real world and what the surprises
will be for example here they replace
the rotor okay in the maintenance and in
the end they got a new rotor and they
were fitting it in the rotor length was
shorter than the required one and that
was a challenge for the plant manager
and we that's one of the aspects we
brought into the classroom apart from
other technical details now with we used
a set of these modules as a course in my
sophomore level class teaching concepts
in engineering design we had two groups
one using the scale studies one using
the lecture mode of teaching the subject
and I am NOT going into the details of
the evaluation but what we found was a
majority of students found this case
study methodology to be interesting
exciting and relevant and useful
and the students realize the connection
of theory and real-world practice
perceived that the method assisted them
in enhancing the learning process and
multimedia materials help to improve
learning driven factors we have also
developed a model to study the
differences between a multimedia lecture
and a written lecture or written notes
how the students perceive it and we have
a publication out of it
and again the learning different factors
like learning interests challenging self
Laporte and learning learn from others
are the important aspects of using this
multimedia we have tried this in
different courses already about 700
Stewart n students went through this we
tried it in business over eight hundred
and eighty students we tried it in
Alabama A&M and other minority
institutions and they found it very
useful now I want to make a sales pitch
here we are as a part of our
dissemination effort we are organizing a
workshop from May 11th to 13th and I
have some brochures here I would
encourage you to ask your colleague or
colleagues to attend to this workshop
the idea here is we want to provide them
hands-on experience of these case
studies so that they can use the modules
in their classes thank you very much
[Applause]
Wallis Department and he made a
presentation Dave would you like to hear
some more
oh sure anyway I'll make this very brief
since I've already said a fair bit about
the subject what I thought I would do is
just briefly describe the course that I
at undergraduate course that I teach
it's a core course of hundred and twenty
students per year and it's a fourth year
course which is the last in the design
and manufacturing series and it's a
course really about the developing
products and the engineering process
involved in that and what we do is we
really motivate the entire learning
experience by putting the students in
the position to develop substantial
products which they really have the
ownership of the idea and they work in
large teams to do this and they also
work with real budgets of six thousand
dollars per team that they can use for
supplies and there's also support and
other materials that we provide as part
of the course and so the goal is really
to build a real working alpha prototype
and to start the course what we do is we
provide them with the technology theme
and really that's about it so for
example last year we had our theme to be
that where you're interested in
developing products that assist the act
of elderly population and our technology
theme is we develop electromechanical
devices pretty broad and so the students
really take it from there and go through
the entire process to develop design and
develop these alpha prototypes examples
of the products design this last year
include a cart what's called a garbage
porter a device that picks up garbage
pills and and is almost like a powered
walker that allows elderly people to
take their garbage out to the curb
which actually is a large issue it's an
issue for my mother in fact but is in
fact a large number of people with that
problem another product which you can
imagine is like be standing lazy boy but
what's unique about it is it also can be
driven
around like a wheelchair so it provides
mobility inside the house well in the
care chair that helps them also get up
and down from the standing position
other products include a powered wagon
because gardening is one of the most
popular activities for elderly people
but it's a powered wagon with a very
nice force-feedback handle so that it
just it actually has no controls but
just feels like a variable light wagon
no matter what you're doing it just
walks along with you based on your
pulling in the handle so that's what we
do and to do that we try to take an
approach where the faculty work very
directly with the students so the teams
that are developing each product there's
15 students for each team there are two
faculty members involved that are really
down working in the shop with them
throughout the process and we're really
following the just-in-time paradigm for
doing this and from a teaching
standpoint this is a very fun and
challenging thing for the instructors
and because you don't know what problem
you're gonna be solving any given day
and you get used to the notion of saying
well I don't know how to solve that but
I think we can figure it out and that's
a very real part of Engineering and and
research for that matter also in
addition to the faculty we have alumni
mentors that work with the teams
typically two to four mentor some of
them in the area some of them at a
distance to provide additional expertise
and to support that we're working on of
course the development of the web-based
modules like I was talking about both on
the process of product development and
also on different topics and we're also
trying to work on access to expertise
through alumni and other interest that
patrons really and so there's a lot left
to do I think on that the latter part of
those support resources but I really do
think that this is uh in some ways the
way to teach product design in a unique
way that can really only be offered
through the facilities that are
residential
the campus can provide I guess it's time
for you to raise issues questions
comments what have you so the floor is
open
yes
no there's a lot the question was are
there other activities going on on
campus and the answer to that is yes
there are quite a few there's CA EES
which is Center for advanced engineering
studies that does a lot there's the MIT
Singapore there's work going on with
Cambridge there's also the Microsoft I
campus initiative which is funding a
number of different proposals to work on
different aspects of use of technology
on campus there's the d'arbeloff funding
which is also really that so there's a
lot of different activities yes and I
believe that's being focused on that
first year yes
teachings when it stops you can hear a
commotion on TV City publications are
you a high priority for
well you know all of us would have
somewhat different answer tourists so my
personal answer would be that I think we
are able to attract Tom Knotts faculty
members who can do extremely good job in
both it's not a case of doing well in
one and to import in the other and it
turns out that our faculty members in
this department excellent teachers and
also they have international reputation
in their field and so I'm not sure it's
made of trade mayor of trade off
it's really doing both jobs extremely
extremely well now just to give you an
example they I'm very pleased this year
that we received through our colleagues
received but MIT call McVicker faculty
fellowship what MIT does is select few
people each year and they will have up
to about 50 people and they give them
special allowance for being a good
teacher it turns out that this year MIT
selected six out of six MIT wide and we
have thousand professors and MIT
selected six and out of six two of them
professors of mechanical engineering so
and in fact one of the professor's
clearly got the recognition because of
his involvement in our undergraduate
teaching 14 of our professors are what
we call designate professors these are
the professors who are implementing our
new undergraduate curriculum the other
ones writing books and indeed avoiding
creative time to make it happen some of
them are not tenured and indeed in we
look at teaching record very very
carefully and if someone is not a good
teacher probably he or she will not be
allowed to stay at MIT as a tenured
faculty member so often we have
discussion on this teaching versus
research but I say one ought to be able
to do a good job in both yes Jim
right this as I said we graduated in the
first class in 1999 and we actually
discussed this need to revamp our
undergraduate curriculum for many years
well finally we decided to implement it
and we had a greater of disagreement as
to when is the right time to improve the
new curriculum some people want to see
all the details worked out before we
implement and the some of us felt that
you can really you cannot really develop
all the details because it takes
enormous amount of effort to do that so
so we decide to do this and essentially
the idea is that we wanted to make sure
that we look at learning from the
students point of view and provide right
context so we felt that by combining
some of these subjects in a single
sequence we can provide the context just
as I said earlier thermodynamics heat
transfer fluid mechanics is in one
sequence and at the beginning there's a
creative controversy because lots of
professors complain about the way that
person in charge was teaching the
subject but now there is no controversy
in fact because students like it you can
think of the way we teach in some of
these subjects like a peeling onion we
teach many of these principles at the
beginning and then we solve series of
more and more difficult problems and
through that students begin to
understand the context they begin to
understand the theories in the context
of how we our problems are solved and I
think it's working out well and and I
can give you some stories some of the
professors in our department didn't like
the way that that particular subject and
I can use some other sequence and I can
give you the same story did not like the
way it was presented and it turned out
that we just hired one of
as senior professors from outside
influence area and he taught the subject
in two different ways and then he came
to the conclusion that new ways better
they're all ways of teaching it and that
that sort of stopped any additional
discussion on the subject because one
person who was not biased one way or the
other
came into teaching of this object and
then the decided that the new way of
teaching is better normally when we
teach it this way students complain a
lot or in the first term in this
subjects a to see two term sequence
first time they complain a lot because
they are given all these basic
principles all at once the ones in
thrown dynamics heat transfer and fluid
mechanics but at the end of the second
term students really feel good about it
if you look at student evaluation that's
how exactly I reckon it comes out and so
that professor who did that was selected
as the McVicker teaching the faculty
fellow this year and and it's you may
think that boasting but in some ways I
guess I am but you know what about young
faculty members was so great
he's on tenured faculty and he anyway he
was elected to be this chair full
professor in the Department of
mathematics and physics at the
University and I am trying hard not to
lose him but it's a it's a very strong
statement that indeed we are very strong
young faculty to be chosen as one of the
few senior faculty members at the camp
University Cambridge and he's not even
tenured here so anyway we have a strong
Factory yes two research projects to
make new intelligent machines more
innovative products but this afternoon
in the education session week we saw it
information technology
only as a tool to deliver the education
to the students as in information
technology be integrated in the
curriculum so that the graduating
engineers will be able to develop
intelligent products well Dave Wallace
is presentation really dealt with that
issue and number of professors are
incorporating technology and many of
their subjects they use a lots of
simulations in in their teaching part I
must confess I guess we're still in the
early phase of introducing information
technology now courses yes the
mechanical engineers learning
information technology subjects to
integrate them into their mechanical
engineering training
for instance sewers is a teaching of
graduate course on the internet the
identities part of the assaulter
registers and both graduate and
undergraduate another graduate of a
freshman sophomore course based on for
the Internet
I believe you're also on a committee to
look into the possibility of yeah I I've
developed both graduate and
undergraduate courses in mechanical
engineering on specifically on the
subject of information and together with
Paul Penfield and just stepped down as
head of electrical engineering computer
science which Ichigo freshman course on
what information is so due to do
freshmen the subject it's got seventy
people in industry pretty well forces on
mechatronics we have graduate courses in
will on information and information and
control actually information is really
quite well integrated at the moment into
our curriculum we open we don't need
requires not require in the other part
but there are many options for other
graduates so we are very serious about
the incorporating information technology
in all phases about undergraduate and
graduate education so I think you will
see more more of this happening in the
in the years and decades to come senior
professors all right people used to take
the car cars and take apart mechanical
devices they don't any long because when
you take them apart put them back
together they don't work all right
so you can't do it now this is this is
seen as a big problem in teaching the
category of how you teach mechanical
director
illiterates however there's a flip side
to this which is that students are
coming in right now are often much
better off in terms of knowing about
information technologies both junior and
senior professors in the department
right how often have you asked a
graduate student you don't fix you know
make your disk drive work right I would
sir plain I've certainly done that up a
bunch of times and these students
actually they come in and some sense you
know they don't know about fixing
machines but they know about fixing bits
right they know thank their pride to
know about this in our freshman course
that would teach out to you and Paul
Penfield is amazing how much those
students know about information and
information technologies it makes it
really easy for us to teach the course
because it's as if you know they were
taking apart cars except they're not
they're taking apart computers
installing discs are installing programs
they know about information technology
so this is what we're teaching them
reflects what they actually come to us
already possessing in fact it's just the
argument what Seth said that we are
teaching now we just created for the
first time this term freshman subject
where students are asked to take things
apart and assemble it understand how
mechanical things really work and in
also at the same time we try to teach
them a little bit about history of
Technology so this is a freshman
elective subject and we think they'll do
it I'm not a good
most important
information technology
Curren into mechanical engineering is
that the whole area of measurement the
society is becoming ubiquitous with
measuring devices and I think it's
absolutely important that our students
know the ramifications of that and how
to deal with the information that those
instruments deliver I think it's
it could be a really important
distinguishing characteristic of the
next generation of students that they
feel is as comfortable using unity
indeed a devices to control and
manipulate and design things as they do
using wheels and ears because that's
where it's at and that is in fact
information technology they need to know
how to information in an economical way
and know the pieces that know it too I
have a graduate course advanced
instrument design which is basically
focused on that on that issue
yeah the to what folks do is that we
have about sixty professors and you can
see that you saw roughly maybe one-sixth
of our department here today and people
in other fields fields like
manufacturing PI instrumentation and so
on so forth they are doing great deal of
the research as well as creat creating
and trying to create educational
paradigms involving IT so you haven't
seen that aspect in fact many of our
manufacturing colleagues are working on
the things that require information
technology as well you haven't seen that
just too many people yes
do you have any suggestions for dealing
with that CV roadblock sure well I guess
the way to think about those materials
way I would think about it is people are
used to spending a long time writing a
book and there is that very large figure
of preparing the materials and that's in
a sense trying to I mean to be honest
with you that same lecture too for me to
do it live in class required about 50
hours of prep because of the lot of the
props were actually used the same but
but but some of that time was production
time some of that time was intellectual
content development the pure
intellectual content development was on
the order of the 50 to 70 hours the rest
of it was some form of production or
rather and so in one of the clear
messages is you know there needs to be
an infrastructure in place that makes it
a tenable proposition so that if you
will with the different people in the
chain of producing the material
contribute in the area that is there you
know most valued competency and so
that's one of the things that would
change because obviously that's not
something you know every faculty member
is going to do for every lecture so so
there needs to be the appropriate chain
and then there needs to be the delivery
mechanism so you can choose the subjects
and do that for the ones where there is
the audience to support it and it
actually I think can fairly quickly end
up being a very economical way to do
things they can do this in above five
days uh so he puts it up 120 hours a
week so 100 hours of effort is not that
much
we any others up the comments yes I said
somethin in the mechanical engineering
education here
it's awakening that Seth mentioned over
here that there is a group of
engineering students have that do not
know years and he's a traditional
mechanical
are we trying to redefine what McKenney
mechanical engineering means or do you
foresee some renaming of mechanical
engineering to to incorporate these new
interdisciplinary aspects of the
language what's happening if if other
departments in the nation follow MIT
would we be looking at
what is really happening here I'm not
really sure how to answer that but we
are really broadening that what it means
to be a mechanical engineer so that
house graduates can deal with the tasks
that we'll be facing in industry even
academia is no longer good enough to
have a mechanical engineering department
solely made of thermodynamics and our
primary conditions and still a large
number of schools do that and indeed
that's one of the motivations for having
this conference is that if we continue
to teach only mechanics and
thermodynamics or what have you and I
don't think they can become a leader
they can only deal with a subset of
overall engineering tasks because
nowadays you cannot deal with overall in
geni tasks without knowing software
without knowing control without knowing
how to deal with the information
technology how to manage people and so
on and so forth and then at least by
exposing our students to what's out
there by creating a big window through
which they can look out and least
knowing that there are such sub branches
of engineering discipline they can
become a more engineer who can become
leaders and who can shape the future of
technology and industry so that's the
goal
certain lies that as to what they want
from these engineers huh
maybe industry should be involved in all
this process as well so mechanical
engineers are really trained with other
it's interdisciplinary IT based
education other ninjas make up notes
relative to the hands-on
I think we we don't believe we want to
lose the some of the hands-on aspects of
of mechanical engineering so we offer
something we call a hands-on Short
Course where they actually take apart an
engine and put it back together and it
has to run or they don't pass and in
fact it's probably the most exciting we
see the kids is when they fire I think
we get lawnmower engines from some one
of our sponsors and when they fire up
that engine and it actually comes up
that's that's one of the highlights of
their sophomore year it turns out terms
of information technology in the
curriculum I think we we offer
measurements at the undergraduate level
and we factor in I mean I even taught an
assembly code to mechanical engineers
for a while because I believe you have
to know what a computer is in the
architecture to succeed now not everyone
agrees with that approach and then in
terms of IT we've offered I think we're
just starting to move down to the
undergraduate we have a course that's
like our senior design and manufacturing
it has rapid prototyping CAD cam type
things we offered that in conjunction so
that's undergrads elective we offered in
conjunction with a smart machines course
so we had teams of grads and undergrads
who had to build a device with embedded
an embedded micro system so it actually
had to carry something out so an
electromechanical system so I think
we're having it both ways I agree with
my colleague here but some of the
restrictions our schools have was and
probably MIT doesn't have is we are we
have to satisfy a bit criteria MIT
probably doesn't have to so we are
restricted to a certain extent to cater
to the industry needs of our region say
for example I am coming from Auburn
Alabama so I we have to have our
industry input into our curriculum
which is the basis of a bet mm
assessment and so that's the reason why
for example my presentation concentrated
on developing modules to help our still
our professors in getting the a bit
2,000 criteria satisfied but MIT
probably has the luxury of not doing it
but that doesn't mean we are not taking
the cue from MIT and the discussions we
have here for example information
technology is integrated in some of our
courses in the form of mechatronics
instrumentation and other things so
that's where the differences
hi I am Vanessa so simplify the
equations of information technology he
goes into the science high school
so yellow is not I mean defining making
anyone related to the fourth question
unless the suspect may be precise and we
are here because a teacher asked how
much each may be a basic movement
[Music]
what is student enrollment where they go
and so on so forth and but basically my
sort of personal view is that we have to
do what is right for students and if you
don't do it the kind of things we are
talking about you cannot even met they
control engines nowadays right and in
management system controls the engine
SOS transmission and without it's an
integrating tool which is an information
technology we cannot do all this one of
the things that are kind of interesting
I'm using and I was going to tell the
visiting committee on monday and and
dear might find it interesting
our macaca and during enrollment at MIT
is still quite high we have 300 some
students sophomores juniors and seniors
and we are the I think in terms of Sue
and aroma we have second-largest
apartment and at MIT for departments
teach about 70% of all our
undergraduates just too then we have
twenty some departments about four
departments teach seventy some percent
as almost 70% somewhere around seventy
percent of our undergraduates and we are
the second largest in terms of
undergraduate enrollment and during last
five years our undergrad enrollment went
down from 300 I think 65 to 315 and we
were sort of wondering why and in
preparation for the visiting committee I
was looking at some of these numbers
very carefully
guess what you know since I look like an
Irishman I can say they say
it's the asian-americans not coming into
Emmy we had about 115 asian-americans
five years ago today we have a 65 so
that the drop is all in asian-americans
again and I blame Confucius teaching
because because come because Confucius
teaching always put these people who
don't do any work and who used it their
hands and one up composed poems as being
the highest class right anyone who had
to use hands with a letter O and over
just one notch award emergency and I
think that culture must permeate with
this all asian-americans because their
parents must tell them something
but it's interesting statistics number
woman students in a decrease number of
the the Caucasian students did not
increase is the asian-americans that
decrease in mechanical engineering so
that the problem that you are alluding
to may have less to do with you know the
all student population leaning toward
computer science or anything like that
but certain segments have certain
cultural bias or whatever the case might
be this is something I'm trying to
understand yes an 85
what happens at the expectation was
society from a professor and also our
students we seem to expect our student
we able to do who are not we're also
within the software be able to the
management would be the rescue would
social aspect us all but in terms of the
program we have four year program
however what they explained MIT how can
you fit all that into the curriculum and
that the food of finishing four years
the debate has been going on ever since
engineering education got started about
150 years ago but if you just look at
just a roved
data it's the answer to that is
relatively simple and and certainly my
colleagues in electro engineering
computer science would differ from me
because they had when different ways the
knowledge our students had to be had to
acquire does our engineering students
had to acquire over these years has
increased all the time in fact people
like to think that the knowledge
required is increasing as that at an
exponential rate
and I'm sure fifty years ago seventy
years ago people said the same thing and
yet we don't live that long I mean our
lives the expectancy went up a little
bit longevity went up a little bit but
it hasn't gone up that much and as a
result we have to codify what we know we
got to be able to somehow improve
efficacy of educational process so that
we can indeed convey more knowledge in
the same period of time at the same time
some of the things we used to teach to
our students are no longer needed
because we have better technology and
they indeed the things I still use my
logarithmic table at home I happen to
have it and whenever the I don't you
have a calculator whatever I use that to
calculate it but our young students I
wouldn't I don't think they would know
what how to use it right but they don't
have to use it because I at least I was
told in class how to use a table rent
but our students don't have to
so I think there is a certain degree of
efficiency efficacy and whatnot you can
bring into teaching by using technology
that's in that sense IT is going to play
a major role
No
in this and just in time is everything
very important so people can just go
into a module and learn what they need
to know so they can do the job yes
terrible yes would you identify yourself
first I should have asked here so that
you are the first one to identify
yourself
it's on trying to change
the changes we're talking about one of
the speakers on speaker
when steadily he was from Indiana
coincidentally and I wanted to respond
to this one of the things he said to me
I'll give a try I think it may get back
to what Dave said about the learning
styles and I think some students respond
to lectures and some some domes so I
think at Purdue we are trying a number
of different teaching styles to address
a number of different learning styles so
we have faculty that don't lecture you
cannot create a kind of thing that they
wall is created on a video and whatnot
without thinking through the entire
process okay and so you know to be
effective in teaching you have to
qualify so that our students when they
leave MIT when they squeeze what they
learn there will be something remaining
in their hand in terms of knowledge and
so so I think it's we will go through a
transition and probably you know the
people said that books are needed
studying of a hundred years ago practice
is more important and so forth we went
through this whole argument that designs
to be taught by letting students
actually just get experience rather than
teaching them in your theories and we
went that discussion by the way went on
in other fields as well right but what
made the engineering education so
effective so efficient is because of
codification so that instead of teaching
how something is should be done we came
out with a control theory by teaching
control theory we have been able to not
deal with control nonlinear systems and
so forth and they would not have been
possible with a scholary war
and writing a book codifying in a
scholarly work okay and so we cannot
diminish the importance of scholarly
work in education otherwise we will just
have a bunch of our moving people
so we just can say this belief that
certainly related to product development
increasingly in a sense the mechanical
engineers are the ones that get it to
work and so what that means is I think
very consistent with a lot of things
retirement there's a lot of have to be
pretty well-rounded people now if that's
what you're implying yes I think the
mechanical engineers they need to have
of course there's a core of the
discipline and you need in some ways I
think to be deep in something but at the
same time will will be increasingly
versed to deal with a lot of these
different situations
I was right it's fair that we better
wrap it up so always ordered at the same
time you know since I'm standing it let
me just say this I think most important
part of engineering education is
teaching students how to look at facts
how to look at basic laws of nature or
basic ways of synthesizing things and
then think logically and the the power
of logical thinking is what we're
teaching and engineering and that can be
applied to number other areas in many
other areas it's interesting it's a john
sununu said is that the one about these
things alumnus seminar not quite sure in
many other fields they draw conclusions
first and they rationalize justified by
bringing all sorts of quotations saying
you so and so so this is same as what I
said but ignoring all other things that
person said but in engineering we don't
do that and I think that power rational
thinking is important all areas and I
personally like to think that some of
our undergraduates will go into other
fields and influence other fields as
well so if you interpret that as meaning
that that is the meaning of liberal
education so be it okay and let's have a
dinner okay thank you
[Applause]